it happened
russian president vladimir putin in
defiance of western warnings about
incurring unprecedented sanctions
sent his warplane soldiers and tanks to
attack ukraine
the big question is what will happen
next
there are multiple possible scenarios
from an outright win for either side to
a new world war where everyone loses
at one end president putin's invasion
topples the government of vladimir
zelensky and moscow then imposes a
puppet regime
this new administration turns the nation
firmly eastwards rejecting previous
desires to join the european union and
the nato defense alliance both red lines
for the kremlin yes
uh
moscow attempts to mitigate the impact
of the west's punitive sanctions forging
ever closer ties to the world's largest
authoritarian power china
president xi jinping would doubtless be
inspired to plan his next move on taiwan
the west is left looking diminished with
its values under threat and this could
well spell the dawn of a new era where
great powers impose their will over
weaker rivals
a second scenario is only marginally
less bleak from a western and ukrainian
perspective
putin succeeds in taking and holding
ukraine's entire coastline stretching
along the black sea and the sea of azov
cutting off the country's ability to
export
it cripples the economy leaving a rump
state to be ruled by a weakened
government in kiev
an east-west german-style divide would
then cut through europe
all parts of ukraine under government
control would be able to build closer
ties with western allies while the other
part of the country would be absorbed
back into the russian sphere of
influence
then there is the very real possibility
of a powerful and effective ukrainian
resistance to counter any russian
occupation or russia-controlled
government
that would drag moscow into a protracted
guerrilla war in ukraine triggering
discontent in russia as the number of
russian soldiers killed and wounded
grows along with the financial cost of
the mission
[Music]
this is a situation that ultimately
threatens president putin's power
it would require western allies to
support ukraine by arming training and
offering other forms of covert help to
whatever resistance force
emerges the west would also need
significantly to increase investment in
their respective armed forces after
decades of neglect
only with the capability and willingness
to use force can they hope to be able to
push back against authoritarian threats
as has been demonstrated by events in
ukraine
[Music]
it's much harder to attack than to
defend meaning that if ukraine's armed
forces can hold out against the russian
invaders they have a chance of beating
them back or at least ensuring that any
russian victory comes at the highest
possible price in terms of soldiers lost
despite being outgunned the ukrainian
military is far better trained and
equipped than when russia first
challenged this country with the
annexation of crimea in 2014
boosting their chances is a steady flow
of weapons and ammunition from a growing
group of allies from the us and the uk
to previously more reluctant states like
germany
reactions
ukraine is putting up a strong fight in
the north east and south slowing and
even halting in places the russian
advance
as president putin has taken the
extraordinary step of ordering the
invasion it's hard to imagine he could
allow it to fail but if ukraine's troops
are able to hold the line then they can
make the move so costly that the russian
leader's own authority at home is
destroyed and his war fails
[Music]
finally there's a chance that the
escalating violence in ukraine prompts
western allies to intervene directly in
the conflict militarily they're already
providing things like anti-tank and
anti-aircraft weapons to the armed
forces but the ukrainian government is
increasingly calling on the west to
impose a no-fly zone believe it
or
not
western jets would then have to shoot
russian aircraft out the sky and destroy
russian air defense systems putting the
two nuclear-armed sides into direct
military confrontation for the first
time a no-fly zone means that you're in
in a in a conflict with russia again our
position remains that we're not going to
do that that scenario could lead to an
uncontrollable escalation in the
conflict far beyond ukraine's borders
possibly even triggering the third world
war
you